hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan in today's I was
having an answer question from one of my
youtube viewers Abdul who is asking
about how to connect passion with
creativity I wanted to know how to do it
want my advice on on how to do it so
Abdul thank you for the question first
off there are some people who are just
more creative than others and that
happens some people were born super
creative and other people are more
analytical and don't seem to have as
much creative juices so that's you know
that's going to happen if you're not the
most creative person I think there's
still hope and where I think it really
lies is if you're doing something that
you're super passionate about and when
you are really excited about something
then you you're you know you're
passionate about you're the expert
you're going to find ways to do things
that other people haven't thought about
and it usually comes from a frustration
source for you so think about things
that you solve because you are really
frustrated with I really wish that this
worked a certain way I really wish that
this could happen you know in an inch in
your industry something that you're
really excited about and usually you do
the research because you're so
passionate about it that you got to find
the solution for it often just to help
you and that's a good source to start
thinking about your creativity because
people will often pay you to do it for
them so whatever frustration you had
often a lot of people have that same
frustration so the bigger the
frustration the more value can add the
more people are going to pay you the
solvent for them so I'd start thinking
about you know things that you're super
excited and passionate about and
frustrations that you had along the way
is you discovered that passion how did
you solve it and maybe there's an
opportunity in their business
opportunity if you be able to help other
people going through similar situations
I hope that helps up do them everybody
watching if you liked the video and you
want to see more please give it a thumbs
up below and I'd also love to hear you
have to think if you have any opinions
on passion or creativity leave it in the
comments or if you have a question as
well I'll be happy to answer it you
really have a comment below and we'll
see you on the next step
set
you